so seeing as you guys recreated possibly
one of the worst greatest films ever
made
I'm about to give you the worst
interview prove it we're gonna give you
the worst interview you've possibly ever
had if you could be on an island and
take three things with you what are
three things you would take my cat my
other cat and my brother if you have two
cats oh yeah me too
yeah one's a fat tabby and one's a bit
of a run I have a fat tabby and a
slightly less fat tabby well I give them
job I give them salary understand five
million dollar on this movie great I
thought you kidding a five million
dollar and they are not grateful nobody
respect my vision a you a cat guy are
you a your cat those were my cat
I literally stole them from him because
you just continual I know you know the
canals are probably many movies now I'm
looking up nicely right who do you
believe in Bigfoot yes yeah because the
world is a better place we believe in
creatures and monster ride around with
the dress maybe do it before you shoot
yourself in the head of blow your brains
out I disagree now I'm gonna quiz you on
the room real quick what's the drink
that Lisa makes Tommy Oh a scotch guy
yeah what changed is Greg make that
everyone notices beard a beard you look
much better change is that absolutely it
was you it was you analyzer I am with
you what happened to the psychiatrist
friend Pete oh he gets switched by he's
another actor right what happened he
disappears oh yeah cuz the actor had
another job
gonna make this thing we are going to go
Sanjana
[Music]